photographer Carsten Peter always needs
a red-hot adrenaline rush and he finds
it coming face to face with Earth's
volcanoes it's something like my
religion depend on the bikinis
yet I'm addicted to the Buchanans to
feed that addiction Carsten and his team
traveled to Ambrym a remote island in
the South Pacific almost 1,200 feet or
360 meters below the surface lies the
maroon crater one of Earth's rarest
phenomenons it is a lake of molten lava
Carsten has come to capture this
infernos tremendous size and power by
descending into the boy lunar the
hardened lava is their biggest danger
yet
every edge every corner could be
disastrous for the Rope the Rope goes
upwards downwards and it will easily be
cut because the volcanic rocks are very
sharp Carsten is obsessed photographing
his beloved volcanoes even on the
descent
finally he stands on a ledge above the
lake of boiling magma if you step one
step too much over here limits it could
be in Austin the lavas temperature
rockets to 1,000 degrees Celsius or
nearly 2,000 degrees Fahrenheit Carsten
Braves the heat that can melt solid rock
volcanic eruption are the most powerful
events here on earth it's like
witnessing the creation of a planet
from the bottom of the inferno Carsten
struggled to show Maroons awesome force
he suddenly realizes how to create that
image but needs help he turns to his
partner and volcanologist from Tessier
I saw Frank down there in close to the
pit and and I I just couldn't believe it
him and the comparison to this huge man
but I needed him to climb up a little
higher
he barely could understand myself
because it was so loud and so noisy
a gust of hot gas could erase from to
nothing still he carefully inches along
the ridge until silhouetted by the
belching vent
for Carsten and from getting that shot
is a risk worth taking even in the
danger zone
in this extreme moment Carsten manages
to show man's frailty against Earth's
ferocious power if there is no one in
the frame you don't have any comparison
and you are lost in the scale and that's
important and touch to that image